Chadwick when you were writing that book
did you write about when John Stewart
went on CrossFire was it man that was
transformative for Tucker I watched it
in real time I think it was the moment
it happened and it was like it was like
humiliating but also he took it
seriously because you could tell he had
a respect for Jon and like he became
like a Pioneer for justice after that it
was incredible John Stewart did no
Tucker tuck Tucker like he started to
step away from the mainstream and was
like maybe this warmongering isn't
necessarily the right way and he he
started to think for himself after that
it was really powerful so behind the
scenes John Stewart he went on that show
and he lambasted Tucker Carlson and his
co-host saying Crossfire is bad for
America it's just you pundits going back
and forth and uh and then as soon as and
and they say it killed the show
Crossfire Crossfire was taken off the
air after that all of America was siding
with John Stewart yes we hate this
fighting I mean look at us now right
yeah after the cameras stopped rolling
John Stewart who's there to promote his
book said to them um you know I miss
came to town and he trashed you guys and
got forward a new station so I think
this worked out well for me it was all
planned